hello everybody my name is nyan i'm the
black female engineer i provide content
for new
and aspiring software engineers and
today we're going to figure out which is
right for
you front end or back end development so
let's get to it so let's start out with
what these two people do
front-end development is responsible for
really everything the user
sees and interacts with while back-end
development
works extensively with databases
everything
that the user saw and the elements they
used they
worked because of the back end developer
so a typical day in the life that you
can expect of the two
will start with front end development a
ux ui designer
has a meeting with their project manager
and them to
work on how to revamp a site an app or
how to create a new one altogether
they figure out how they would like the
layout to be how they would like the
user
experience to look like and after they
wrap up
they bring that report or
they bring you know their findings and
everything to
you and now it's your job to bring
their vision to life now moving on to a
back-end developer
the back-end developer their manager may
go to them and say look
we need to make sure that our site is
running as fast as possible
and we need to make sure that our search
results
that they are as accurate as possible so
let's say you work at
some type of shopping uh company and so
what really they'd be asking for is
let's make sure that users when they
input in their search box black top
black
shorts the proper items pop up for them
and so yeah those are the two days in
the lives you can kind of expect
of the two different developers so now
let's move on to technologies
so a front-end developer is pretty
straightforward the things that they
are expected to know or learn they need
to know html and css start there
then they need to learn javascript and
then finally
some type of javascript framework
typically react
angular or view that's
really it that's really all there is to
it
um i mean the languages themselves they
are a whole thing
but in terms of what to learn and what
to know it's pretty straightforward
which is not really the case for
back-end developers
back-end developers they have quite like
a slew of options
in terms of what languages they're
expected to know it kind of goes down to
personal preference
or what the company themselves use so
this can be
anywhere from python to ruby to java to
c
sharp it really goes down to preference
and so i
recommend kind of trying out the
different languages and seeing which
ones
you resonate more with and going from
there
now on top of a language they need to
know they also need to know some type of
database and so really the most popular
three options are mongodb
mysql and oracle and so yeah these
databases are responsible for
like let's say a user creates a profile
and they have their first name last name
age email all of that that information
is stored within
a database and so that is why that is
just such a pertinent
part of the role next let's talk salary
i was pretty i remember when i was going
through this process i was pretty
shocked to see quite a salary difference
within the rolls
so the three locations we'll look at for
salaries are
new york toronto and london so starting
with new york
front end developers can expect to make
about eighty nine thousand
dollars in new york city while back end
developers
can expect to make an average of about a
hundred and twelve thousand dollars
these figures were taken from glass door
all of the figures were
and you see this big difference
this stays consistent throughout the
different locations so let's move on
to toronto in toronto front end
developers can expect to make
70 thousand dollars while back-end
83 000 so not as big of a gap but still
a pretty considerable gap now going to
london
front-end developers can expect to make
000 euros while back-end developers can
expect to make
62 000 euros and so pretty consistently
back-end developers make
more now why is that well
back-end developers do obtain a lot more
risk than front-end developers a mistake
made by back-end developers
is much more costly than a mistake made
by a front-end developer
a back-end developer mistake can cause
the
site to crash it can cause you know
hackings it can
just really create a slew of problems
that can take a long time to resolve and
are just so so costly to the company
while front-end developer they don't
really have that same risk
even if they do you know and when they
do make mistakes
it's nothing that would be
as high caliber as the back end
developer typically i mean
tell me if you know you're a fine
developer and you like made your whole
building blow up because you forgot the
color of a back i don't know but
um yeah it's really not as costly
and so you know the greater the risk the
greater the reward but at the same time
heavy lies the head that wears the
king's crown
so you kind of need to look at these
things
but the back end developer may be the
right place for you
especially when you look at
personalities so
the personalities of these two
developers will start with back end
a backend developer is seen as more of a
problem solver you know minded person if
you've liked puzzles all your life that
is a good sign that you'll like
back in development however the
personality of front-end developers
is very detail-oriented you're
perfectionist because
you care about the look and feel of your
project you care about the aesthetics
and you care about you know design and
just the ability to be more creative
one thing i read was that front end
development is for people who have
always wanted to be designers
but never learned to draw which is
actually really funny because when i was
six years old i wanted to be a fashion
designer
and so i find that um really funny
because i love front end development
that is just my
niche like put me in coach like that is
where i belong
um but where front-end developers
are very detail-oriented and
make sure that things look pretty
back-end developers
they just want things to work they do
not care if they had to
throw things onto the wall like as long
as it works at the end of the day they
will sleep just fine
and so um yeah those are just some
considerations to make
in looking at which is right for you
don't forget to subscribe especially if
this is not your first video it really
helps me out supports
my channel and let me know which you're
considering more are you more front-end
or are you more back-end
or do you like a little bit of both and
you really don't care what would be the
deciding factor for you
would be the salary but i hope you liked
this video please leave a thumbs up if
you did
and i'll see you all later bye y'all